[Music]
you've been in so many funny movies you
had this very memorable scene memorable
to me and I think to others in we're the
Millers where you feel up Jennifer
Aniston's frontal area yes we have the
image from that from that scene and I'm
curious how did that scene come about
was that yes script
my husband's screensaver how did your
husband react to that obviously a lot of
texts that day asking me all of a sudden
about I was like oh really
white so all of a sudden interested we
I'm proud to say very proud we came up
with that mrs. Aniston and I which I'm
very very proud to take that to take
that banner
there's no banner that was a suddenly
Game of Thrones warehouse Aniston boom I
actually think the gentleman we're doing
a little bit dirtier deeds behind us I
think like I remember
yeah he's sticking his wet finger and
Sudeikis is Nick Offerman yeah yeah yeah
a little more invade your husband has
that he actually has viewed this scene
probably several times multiple times
for you you walk it right winding it
just like all the time he keeps it fresh
he we've been together a long time how
long you been married we just had our 11
year wedding anniversary
oh that's about as long
[Applause]
married 12 years in a couple days good
big plans for university I don't know
all right my wife will tell me I know
we'll go to Burger King yeah I'm like
your dad it's funny yeah handicapped
parking go to Burger King all right we
have a clip here from The Secret Life of
Walter Mitty I absolutely adore this
film it's so funny it's so good and
anything we need to know for this clip I
play Ben Stiller sister Odessa I'm a
struggling actress and I've ambushed him
in his place of employment in this but
from the secret life of walter mitty I
guess so what are you doing here mom
made you your favorite Clementine cake
aren't you supposed to be at the
retirement place with her getting the
piano moved in I just got a phone call
about really big audition so can you go
finish it no I can't I'm late Walter I I
don't think you're seeing this from what
I need what do you what do you need I
need to be Rizzo and Reese and I
understand that my audition rizz go
wisdom wisdom
she's tough and tender do me a favor
please make sure mom's piano gets moved
in all the way all right don't go to
Rizzo
you
[Applause]